I have an update.
NASA has said that there will
be a hardware random number
generator on the rover
that we have access to.
And after that, they
made one more comment.
They reminded me that we
just need our algorithm
to work in practice.
For something to
work in practice,
it means that there's always
some possibility of error,
but perhaps the
possibility is so small
that we ignore it in practice.
And if this sounds
crazy, just realize
that in the physical world,
nothing is ever certain.
There is always
chances for error.
For example, chip packaging
contains small amounts
of radioactive contaminants,
and when these decay,
they release alpha
particles, which can actually
flip bits in memory and perhaps
change a number unexpectedly.
And even more
interesting, cosmic rays
can also cause soft errors.
We can never remove the
chance of error completely.
And I asked NASA, exactly,
well, what error of probability
is acceptable?
And they said, we
just need to make sure
that the probability of
error for a given trial
is less than the odds of hitting
the lottery twice in a row.
And the odds of
hitting the lottery,
say 649, twice in a row, is 6
times 10 to the negative 14.
So let's just be safe and
round down, and say our error
probability is 10
to the minus 15.
Safe enough.
We will not expect
to see an error,
and it could run hundreds
or thousands of times.
Now, my question is,
would access to randomness
help us speed up a
decision algorithm,
such as this primality test?
And this is a deep question.
So let's step back and
look at the big picture.
Given some collection of
integers from 1 to some limit,
n, say, let's think of it
as our universe of integers.
We can always divide a
collection into two sets.
And a decision
problem can actually
be thought of as a
partition into two sets.
For example, provided
some n is n less than 100,
it will output yes for all
integers less than 100.
So here is one collection.
And no for all others,
which is another collection.
OK, so let's now focus
on recognizing primes
with the decision.
And ideally what we would
like is some simply computed
criteria that all primes satisfy
and no composites satisfy.
Now if we knew some
simple pattern which
describes the location
of all primes,
and only primes, then
given some number n,
we could simply check if
n follows that pattern.
But the problem is that so
far, no exhaustive and simply
computed pattern has
been found for all primes
and no composites, or all
composites and no primes.
But we do know fast tests
for most composite numbers.
So, for example, a
simply computed criteria
would be a test for evenness.
And all even numbers
are divisible by 2.
It's fast, because we can tell
if something's even by just
looking at the last digit.
And even as n grows, the
problem doesn't get any harder.
We just look at that
last digit, also known
as the low-order bit.
Now realize that we can
use this evenness test
as a low-quality
composite test, in that,
we could have some algorithm
accept an integer, n,
and all our algorithm does
is check if it's even.
If it is even and greater
than 2, then we know,
with 100% certainty,
it is composite,
because we have proof.
Think of 2 as our
composite witness.
However, if not, then
we aren't exactly sure.
If it's odd, it could be prime,
since all primes are odd,
or it could be one of the many
composites which are odds,
such as 9 or 15.
And this massive region
of odd composites
makes for an unacceptable test.
Now, to be clear,
let's draw this.
Provided some n, n can be
either prime or composite.
If n is prime, our algorithm
will say prime 100%
of the time, since no primes are
even that are greater than 2.
And it will never say composite
when a prime is provided.
However, if n is
composite, our algorithm
will say composite about 50%
of the time and prime 50%
of the time.
So this means that if our
algorithm outputs composite,
it means it found proof,
a composite witness.
However, if our
algorithm outputs prime,
we know there is an unacceptably
large chance of error.
Up until now our
strategy has dealt
with this unacceptably
large error by iteration.
And let's draw the
flow of our machine.
Given some n, our
machine does a series
of divisibility tests
starting at a is 2.
It asks, does a divide n?
And if it doesn't
divide n, then we
can eliminate all
of this region.
Then it asks the next
question, does n divide 3?
And if not, then we
eliminate that whole section.
And does n divide
5, 7, and so on.
And notice these are disjoint
sets which gradually fill up
all possible composites.
Now if we ever answer
yes along the way,
then we have proof
that n is composite.
And a, whatever it is at
that point, is our witness.
So we halt an output
composite from our algorithm.
Otherwise, we continue
trying until we exhaust
all possible composites, until
we hit the square root of n
since we know, remember,
every composite number
n must have a factor less than
or equal to the square root
of n.
So this really leads
to the final question
in our algorithm.
If no witnesses are
found, and a is greater
than the square root of n,
then we suddenly have proof,
and we halt an output prime.
So realize we have two exit
paths through our algorithm.
Both paths represent
proof of certainty
that n is either
prime or composite.
And when n is prime, we
try all possible divisors,
and we basically
rule them all out,
and that is our proof
that n is prime.
The problem with
this strategy is
that our test value
a, at minimum,
requires us to cycle through
every prime starting from 2
to the square root of n.
So as n grows, the number
of primes grow with it.
It results in too many
iterations in the worst case,
such as when we provide
a prime to our algorithm.
Looking at the big
picture, now, realize
it's providing proof
when n is prime,
which we now know we
don't exactly need.
No one said we
needed to prove it.
We just needed to be 99.9999,
15 9's percent certain.
So we actually need to think
about the composite test that's
being used in our algorithm.
Remember, our fastest trial
division primality tests,
thus far, have tried to use
prime patterns, such 6k,
or all primes are of the
form 6k plus or minus
1, to help walk along
the primes only,
and eliminate many of the
composites to save time.
And remember, a
test like this can
be turned into a composite test.
That is, given some integer n is
of the form 6k plus or minus 1,
then we could say
it's probably prime.
But there are many
composites, still,
which follow this pattern.
It doesn't include primes
only, just all primes
and some composites.
And we can think of these
extra composites as a leak.
And this leak is
our source of error.
Now, if we invert it and
ask, is n not of the form 6k
plus or minus 1, then we
can say with 100% certainty
it is composite.
So the leak is our source
of error on the prime side.
But in this case,
it's unacceptable.
It's not a non-negligible error.
There's a much
larger probability.
We need to define a
new composite testing
procedure which is able
to shrink this space
and make the chance of error
negligible, which means we'll
need to review how we can
actually shrink errors
with iterations.
I think we should now post
our ideas below regarding,
what kind of tests might
we want to perform?
And also, more importantly, how
could a random number generator
really help us?